ça c'est ma fille oui l'automne dernier
sa vie basculer lors d'une banale visite
chez sa pharmacienne
[Musique]
un diagnostic lancé à voix haute dans la
pharmacie parce que son médecin avait
Tommy de lui annoncer
pour parce que j'ai reçu un diagnostic
de Alzheimer il y a environ trois mois
déjà elle peine à se débattre dans le
système pour avoir de l'aide sa mémoire
commence à faire défaut elle refuse de
finir ses jours en résidence une réalité
qu'elle connaît pour y avoir travaillé
pendant 20 ans comme préposé au
bénéficiaire
je me pas y aller moi non plus je veux
pas aller là c'est pour ça que je
demande l'aide de médical à mourir parce
que je veux plus mais je veux pas me
rendre aux couches là je vais pas me
rendre là hors de question là mais
plusieurs médecins ont des appréhensions
des lois proposé non je ferai pas Claude
Rivard pratique souvent l'aide médicale
à mourir mais il ne la donnerait pas à
quelqu'un qui ne se souvient même plus
l'avoir demandé le problème c'est qu'on
veut donner le soin à des gens qui sont
plus AP qui sont des mains et qui sont
plus capables de dire oui je le veux
alors que le soin doit être donné selon
ce qu'il y avait déterminé des années
auparavant c'est complètement autre
chose là le projet de loi prévoit que le
formulaire serait signé au début de la
maladie on y préciserait à quel stade
l'aide médicale à mourir serait
administré et c'est un membre de
l'entourage appelé tiers de confiance
qui devrait décider quand donner l'aide
médicale à mourir c'est vraiment le
dilemme le problème principal sur de la
démence heureuse est-ce que les proches
et les soignants accepteront de donner
l'aide médicale à mourir à un aîné qui
semble confortable moi maintenant je
peux dire quand je ne reconnaîtrai pas
ma famille je veux recevoir l'aide
médicale à mourir mais c'est très
possible que quand je reconnaîtrai pas
ma famille soit heureux dans le moment
présent quelque soit heureux de de
manger de participer aux activités donc
ça c'est la grande question est-ce que
si je suis dans cette condition là je
devrais quand même avoir l'aide médicale
à mourir surtout si la personne démente
manifeste une opposition est-ce que
quand le patient demain fait un
mouvement de retrait parce qu'il veut
pas être piqué puisqu'il veut pas avoir
son autre cathéter est-ce que faut que
ça soit interprété comme un refus de
recevoir l'aide à mourir plusieurs
pensent qu'il faut réserver l'aide
médicale à mourir au stade avancé des
maladies ça nous paraît important que
l'aide médicale à mourir qui aurait été
demandé de manière anticipée soit
considérée comme un soin de fin de vie
dans un contexte de déclin avancé c'est
la meilleure BM malgré sa foi Marcella a
du mal à croire que Québec puisse
refuser l'élargissement vous sentiriez
comment
si on refusait d'élargir pour les
Canadiens
ça serait vraiment très désespéré
majeur pour les députés qui vont étudier
la question ici David gentil les
Radio-Canada Montréal